we already knew some of the name set to  compete on Dancing with the Stars at  season 21 dopers are unconfirmed at the  whole cast on Good Morning America  Wednesday morning or here is Kim Zolciak  this one keeps it all in the family  let's hear it for Tamar Braxton  give it up for Paula Deen  a late addition to our cast last night  I'm thrilled actually to introduce him  he was one of three Americans who took  down a terrorist on a packed train in  Paris ladies to get him a big round of  applause for American hero Alek  skarlatos  the celebs have less than two weeks to  prepare for their dancing debut season  21 premieres September 14th